[Música]
hablamos de economía hoy viernes en
directo américa ya está conmigo en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy buen
día bienvenida hablemos de argentina que
llega a las elecciones legislativas en
plena tensión económica y también
cambiaria a daniella hola raúl muy
buenos días y feliz viernes para usted
pues en las principales fuerzas
políticas ya sabemos que cerraron la
campaña electoral de cara a los comicios
del domingo y eso genera incógnita en el
mercado financiero que ya ha tenido que
lidiar con una fuerte devaluación de la
moneda argentina la cotización del dólar
en el mercado informal lleva días en
máximos históricos y ya supera los 206
pesos por unidad y el dólar que vende el
banco de la nación también está en un
histórico de 105 pesos y que decir
entonces a nivel de la situación
cambiaria claro porque la atención no es
solamente cambiaria también es
macroeconómica raúl claro eso se acaba
de conocer que la inflación en octubre
fue de 52 1% interanual es decir frente
a octubre del año pasado eso es lo que
han subido los precios de la canasta
familiar pero si se miran los precios al
consumidor en lo corrido del año han
crecido 41 8% esto supera lo que
registramos en todo el 2020 que fue
36,1 por ciento y lo que más sube son
los alimentos y las bebidas no
alcohólicas pues recordemos raúl que
además de ser el segundo país más
inflacionario de la región después de
venezuela argentina también arrastra
casi cuatro años de recesión
bueno angeli cambiamos ahora de
información porque los empleados de una
multinacional de alimentos están en este
momento en huelga estamos hablando mucho
de comida esta semana ramsay y también
le voy a mencionar una empresa que
seguramente conoce usted ha comido
kellogg's por supuesto me encantan los
cereales de esa marca el elefante de
melvin sí me encanta el truco cristal
pues se trata de ellos desde el 5 de
octubre más de 1400 trabajadores de
cuatro plantas de esta multinacional
están en huelga y pues ellos son los que
fabrican todas las marcas de cereales la
empresa presentó una demanda ante un
tribunal quejándose de que están
bloqueando las entradas e intimidando a
los empleados de reemplazo
amenazándolos y advirtió también la
compañía que las conversaciones ya
expiraron escuchemos
y hemos hecho todo lo posible por
construir un puente hacia un nuevo
acuerdo pero esos esfuerzos se han
encontrado con rechazos y demandas poco
realistas el sindicato no parece
interesado en revisar sus propuestas o
explorar soluciones creativas para
resolver estos problemas
daniela me preocupa y le quiere
preguntar entonces qué está pasando con
estas empresas de alimentos bueno pues
mire los multinacional los trabajadores
de la multinacional de cereales esta de
la que estamos hablando que tuvo en el
tercer trimestre ventas por más de 3600
millones de dólares y ganancias de 300
millones se han animado a ir a huelga
este año con la esperanza de tener
mejores salarios en medio de una grave
escasez de trabajadores en eeuu y
después de haber trabajado durante
largas jornadas en la pandemia pero esto
no solamente les pasa a ellos a
comienzos de este año fueron a huelga a
los empleados de una planta de frito-lay
muy rico también y otros en cinco
plantas de nabisco todos de alimentos y
en las empacadoras de carne de todo el
país los sindicatos han estado
negociando exitosamente aumentos
significativos para los sueldos de los
empleados hablábamos starbucks esta
semana que equilibrar un sindicato pues
vamos a ver entonces qué va a pasar con
estas empresas de alimentos daniela
nosotros cambiamos información nos
venimos a nuestra región el sur del
continente americano porque empero hay
confusión por la promesa de un aumento
del salario mínimo porque esta confusión
bueno mire en el discurso del balance de
los 100 días de pedro castillo él dijo
ningún trabajador va a ganar menos de
1000 soles al mes estos son más o menos
250 dólares pues mire lo que pasó
hubo mucha gente que se ilusionó pero
después el mandatario matizó el mensaje
y dijo que no se trataba de un
incremento como tal sino de un subsidio
de 70 soles mensuales y que va a ser
temporal desde abril de 2018 el salario
mínimo está fijado en 930 soles que
equivalen a unos 231 dólares y desde
entonces no ha aumentado de todas
maneras raúl una eventual alza así sea
permanente beneficiaría a una poca
cantidad de trabajadores porque porque
en este país 7 de cada 10 son informales
pero igual nada raro en nuestros
dirigentes latinoamericanos prometiendo
algo en campaña y luego cambiando la
jugada vamos con los indicadores
económicos daniela bueno las acciones
asiáticas cerraron la semana al alza
raúl los inversionistas confían en que
la alta inflación de eeuu es un fenómeno
que terminará pronto y las acciones
europeas alcanzan máximos históricos el
viernes las acciones de lujo volaron
alto por cuenta de las sólidas ganancias
de richmond que es dueño de cartier ha
tenido usted algo cartier no espero que
me lo regalen es mi cumpleaños hablando
que viene daniela porque puesto yo sé
que usted es una mujer muy emprendedora
y que puede comprarme ese regalo siempre
del dia daniela el euro al día del
soltero o no no no los célebres como le
pareció así si hay 34 mil 475 millones
de dólares las ventas del día del
soltero en china que se celebró el
jueves este es el festival de compras
por excelencia en este país según el
gigante mayorista alibaba que presenta
pues todas sus cifras a pesar de que las
ventas aumentaron 8 como 45 por ciento
se trató del crecimiento más lento desde
que se creó la festividad en 2009 bueno
daniela y con
la festividad del día del soltero
nosotros nos vamos hasta glasgow ahí nos
están esperando nuestras enviadas
especiales específicamente luisa pool y
vamos en segundos con ella bueno señor